وقف الطرد
الفلسطينيون من بيوتهم في الشرق
القدس ويجلب في نهاية المطاف
أخيرًا هذا الطاقم المشؤوم أيضًا
نهاية
أعتقد أننا بحاجة إلى معالجة شيئين
الشيء المهم الذي غالبًا ما يتم تجاهله
وماذا اليوم ، والمثير للاهتمام ،
صحيفة اسرائيلية ليبرالية يسارية
هآرتس هي الحقيقة
أن إسرائيل والفلسطينيون انتهت
50 سنة هكذا لمدة نصف عام
احتلت لقرون ولا شعب
لا يمكن لأي مجتمع أن يفعل ذلك
تحمل شيئا
غالبًا ما تكون التفاصيل مباشرة
تجاهل ألمانيا وأوروبا
العنف المستمر ضدهم
فلسطيني من قبل الإسرائيليين
استوطن الجيش من قبل المستوطنين
العنف الاقتصادي كل يوم
العنف حيث الجيش نقاط التفتيش
يتم احتجازه وعدم معرفة متى
كذلك يسمح بالطرد من
تملك منازل آخر في ost
القدس تحاول المصادرة
من الأرض هدم المنازل كلها
الذي أدى إلى نقطة حيث
احتل الفلسطينيون محطما محطما
على وشك الانفجار
هي القصة طويلة المدى
[موسيقى]
القصة قصيرة المدى تعتمد
إلى جانب واحد لا معنى له
حساب قصير الأجل منتج
تصعيد سياسة الحكومة
نتنياهو أيضا فعل الأمرين بالأمس
من اليوم في العديد من المقالات للغاية
عملت بوضوح لماذا يجب أن
الحكومة الإسرائيلية في إسرائيل
الشرطة في منتصف شهر رمضان
أن دمشق حيث الناس في
اجتمعوا في آخر يوم الصيام
أغلق لماذا عليك أن تفعل مع ضخمة
عنف الشرطة في مطرقة الشريف
غزو ​​رابان 2
[موسيقى]
ما هو مطلوب الآن في الأول
الخطوة هي التزام هائل من جانبها
الولايات المتحدة من جانب الأوروبيين وليس كذلك
عرض ألمانيا الماضي عندما تنظر
في ألمانيا كصديق مقرب
تعتبر إسرائيل ثم ينبغي للمرء
اليوم فقط مع أقرب أصدقائه
يتكلم المتشيلات ويقولون هذه السياسة
يؤدي إلى عكس ما تفعله بالضبط
أراد تحقيق خفض التصعيد
يتحدث الحرز للفلسطينيين
يستخدم كل القنوات للتواصل مع حماس
الحديث الذي كان دائمًا ممكنًا
خمسة عشر عاما الماضية لها رأي
قادة الفلسطينيين في اسرائيل
وقف الطرد
الفلسطينيون من بيوتهم في الشرق
القدس ويجلب في نهاية المطاف
أخيرًا هذا الطاقم المشؤوم أيضًا
نهاية